the world is thought to be experiencing
one of the most extreme long lasting and
widespread Heat Wave and drought events
we've ever seen this is China's jaling
river it's a tributary of the Yangtze
and the entire region is robbed of water
for hydroelectricity and crop yields are
expected to suffer here you can see
successive days of extremes the length
Geographic spread and the severity of
temperatures and drought exceed anything
in China since records began
and of course Europe has been
experiencing extreme conditions too if
you see me then weep it reads on this
hunger Stone here on the elb river
warnings to the Future carved during
once deadly droughts centuries ago this
is an index of below average rainfall
for Europe and you can see the lowest in
red the past three months exceptionally
dry over a very large area and the
Western U.S is exceptionally hot and dry
too Lake Mead shrinking to reveal land
not seen since the reservoir was built
in 1935. so is it possible these extreme
heat waves happening concurrently around
the globe are connected some climate
experts suggest high-altitude air
currents called waspy ways linked to the
jet stream could be part of it
there is some evidence to suggest we
often get these kinds of extreme heat
events during periods of what's known as
atmospheric blocking and this creates
what you might have heard called a heat
Dome like we saw in the Pacific
Northwest last year and this essentially
traps any weather underneath it and kind
of makes it stationary so you get really
prolonged hot spells or actually in some
cases really put on cold spells as well
there's evidence stalling of the jet
stream could be influenced by the
warming of our planet we're already
seeing climate change push up
temperature extremes Are We Now
witnessing it destabilize the
established patterns that rule our
weather